online shoppers may soon have to pay
extra to cover sales tax the Supreme
Court ruled yesterday that states can
now force online retailers to charge a
sales tax even if the company doesn't
have a physical presence in that state
the court estimates online retailers
cause states between eight and thirty
three billion dollars every year by not
collecting sales taxes President Trump
tweeted that the decision is quote a
great victory for consumers and
retailers CBS News contributor Nicholas
Thompson is editor in chief of wire he's
here at the table we always like that
hey Nick good to see you again
so how are consumers feeling victorious
about this if now you have to pay sales
tax borne before you didn't I think this
is generally a good move I did not
understand from tweet I don't know why
it's good for consumers okay simmers
will pay more taxes I mean consumers
will be paying more taxes Nick Tom
states will have more money and they
will build better roads that will
benefit from it
no that's surprising for a Republican
who tends to want lower taxes just in
all instances normally but that's not
the question what's this gonna change
for for retailers so what it means for
retailers is that online more people
will charge more taxes and more
locations so there will be more of a
parity right there are a lot of people
who argue that one of the reasons Amazon
has done so well is that they haven't
had to collect sales taxes over the last
20 years Amazon now does to a large
extent collect them but this has been a
real boon for online retailing and so
you can say it's been one of the things
that has helped push brick-and-mortar
retailing into so many problems so this
will help the brick-and-mortar stores at
the expense of the online stores in fact
one of Amazon's biggest competitors
Walmart says this decision is going to
close that loophole yeah it will close
that loophole and make it fair the thing
is we're now twenty years past the point
where that was a big reason people
shopped online people don't shop online
because they don't to pay sales tax it's
a small V Nia the reason you do it is
convenience the data and all of that so
it's a little bit late if your goal was
to level the playing field right so the
biggest windfall is for the states and
communities you get these taxes right
that's it's it's great for states that
are able you mean the states have to
pass laws and then they can now collect
them what if what am I doing if I'm
paying online am I now gonna start
paying more everywhere yeah I mean you
do probably pay some sales taxes on some
purchases on some stores and you'll just
pay a higher percentage on more stores I
mean one of the things that's super
interesting is why did this even go to
the Supreme Court right
should have been a congressional matter
but Congress just has not been able to
sort this out over the last 25 years and
that was actually the big thing that the
Supreme Court was debating was do we
even should we even be deciding this
this violate the Commerce Clause so it's
really interesting that this important
legislative matter came to the court
instead of Congress dealing with it so
you look at it as a fair decision that's
what you're saying I think it's a
reasonable decision that will make taxes
clear like I think stores should have
the same tax burdens whether you're
online or whether you're you know a
physical location I think it makes it
clearer I think it makes it fair but it
doesn't mean you're gonna pay more for
them stuff you're gonna have to ship
stuff to your friends in New Hampshire
Thomasson with a new low poll that he's
thank you to Nick Thompson tax advisor